what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to do
a vlog of what i do in like a normal um
day so today i'm starting my day by
cleaning my room and doing my laundry
but first things first you guys already
know it's time to step on the scale
okay 189.8 so like pretty much the same
thing as yesterday i wasn't expecting
too much of a change this is what my
room looks like now
very messy i know but i'm about to clean
it i've been
um i was driving back and forth a lot
when i was
um before so it was just hard to keep
everything clean but yeah i'm about to
clean all of this oh my gosh this
lighting is not great
i just like wash my face for the day
and i don't care what anyone says on
this channel
look at it wait look at my arms they're
strong they just got a layer of fat
so once i get rid of like 10 to 15
pounds
maybe 28 my arms are gonna be strong as
hell
first i'm gonna put like moisturizer on
second
i actually try to put on sunscreen every
day i don't sometimes i forget
i'm trying not to get wrinkles so i just
have this like sunscreen stick
and i just like go like that all right
guys i cleaned my room a little bit it's
not perfect it's just like better
i'm cleaning the sheets that's why those
are like like that
um these are my clothes i'm gonna wear
later
and this is bathroom i'm gonna give you
guys a tour of the upstairs you guys
want to see the upstairs
so you go up the spiral staircase
and then so this is like the
area if i want to shoot like content on
the couch or
i'll play guitar on the couch and like
record it whatever
that's not my favorite part my favorite
part of my room is the studio
um so there's chair there camera there
um this is where i shoot like content on
youtube
usually i move that chair over there
when i have guests
and it's kind of cool because this can
be like closed
i don't really have a reason to close it
but at least i have it i don't know
but yeah this is the room from the top
got a little shelf there
[Music]
oh my god guys i'm traumatized i was
literally just
doing the second egg oh my god you
you it's like an oh ew
i'm actually so grossed out by the eggs
but i'm just eating a piece of sausage
for breakfast
okay so i had a friend invite me
downtown to this market
okay it's raining but it's kind of cool
because if it's not there's like a
rooftop
bar all right this is kind of a cool
area
here all right this is the matcha latte
that i was recommended
i'm a little early so i've got this
seat and i want to see if i like it
oh that's good that's really good
all right guys this is the sushi i
ordered
as i was really on my way to go to the
gym but i somehow ended up at the theme
i don't know how i got here but i'm here
then um
you like chasing behind this tick tocker
downtown
and i'm gonna ride it it's gonna be fun
can you not hit me
[Music]
okay guys since i got sidetracked going
to the gym today
um i'm about to do this 30 minute
workout
probably on the treadmill lift some
weights over there
maybe go on the peloton who knows but
you're just gonna have to take my word
for it because i'm about to end this
vlog i'll talk to you guys next
time